SCC this is an important acronym again
it's a bit of a hat but it's a helpful
access the way people remember it is
they call it all stations to central ok
there are there are a few other ways to
remember the letters in order like just
like neo never eats only because that
kind of thing
but most of the other opinions alright
so I'm going to say with all stations
essentially okay
the reason it's useful is if you draw
yourself a set of axes like this okay
and if we I could put the unit circle on
here I don't need to for now if I write
these letters in order it's going from
first to second third and fourth
quadrants okay what this indicates is
for a particular angle which of the trig
ratios write all of them just sign just
an or just cos which of them are
positive okay so let me show you how
this works with these examples I just
did okay we did cos x cos x equals MA
and it's from Norton 360 so I'm going to
use this technique instead of this one
right the first thing I'm going to do is
I'm gonna go for my calculator and don't
tell me 60 degrees is the first angle
okay so where do cos inverse of 1/2 this
process is still the same okay I get 60
degrees now to get the second solution
right instead of appealing to a graph I
appeal to this guy right
all stations to central that's um all
are positive in this quadrant sine is
positive in this quadrant 10 is positive
in this quadrant and cos is positive in
this quadrant okay so you can see I have
a positive value here right I've already
got my first quadrant angle from look to
90 there he is right there the
calculator will always hand that one to
you but to get my second solution I look
for where else is cos positive and you
can see it's in the 1/2
three fourth quadrant do you see that
okay so in this quadrant over here
here's how I get these answers I go 360
take away whatever that first angle was
okay
in this third quadrant I'll do 180 plus
whatever that angle is and in the second
quadrant I'll do one a take away
whatever that angle was okay
so using this scheme you can see all
right well if my first angle was sixty
my second one will be 360 take away
sixty which is three hundred which is
just what we got before okay so that was
the first one how about how about this
one over here ten theta equals one okay
reach for your calculator it's positive
so your calculator hands you the first
answer which is 45 degrees then you're
searching for your second it's up look
at your quadrants right one two three
four in which other quadrants is 10
positive and it's just a third quadrant
right there is 10 is positive over here
okay if I were to put in an angle
between 90 and 180 10 will give me a
negative right you can see there he is
he's a negative so what I want is the
third quadrant which is 180 plus
whatever my angle was which is 225 the
same answer that I got before okay now
as you can see this is dramatically
quick off right no graphing required
okay so that's kind of like a really
attractive thing about this process okay
but this is my caution right there's two
problems with doing that number one you
must master graphing there's no way to
get around graphing if you want to go
and do to unit you're going to be
graphing till the cows come home so
there's no point trying to like pull off
graphing you're gonna have to get your
head around that skill anyway and if you
want to rely on this because you can say
who would I'd have to graph you just
pull off the enamel okay that's the
first thing the second thing is like why
is it this one second or third or fourth
quadrant it's kind of black magic right
it's like why does it give me the right
answer
because all stations to center-right
that's not the real reason why but your
real reason is because of these graphs
that's just kind of a helpful way over
milk okay so this is quicker it's like
ten times quicker okay but it doesn't
give you the understanding that you'll
need to progress further okay